[Music]
john is in charlotte north carolina hey
john welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave uh nice to talk with you a
long time fan a first-time caller
actually attended your financial peace
university at our methodist church a
number of years ago and really really
enjoyed it uh glad to see that my wife
and i are now debt free good for you and
uh have been for for some time now so uh
you've really helped us out in in our
finances over the years
but uh i i didn't want to to call in
because i i've got perhaps a common
problem with
college age kids and
i think you've touched on this
in the past but
we have three daughters our middle
daughter is a freshman
at a university two hours away
a great kid
she was senior class president athlete
of the year in high school
uh she's got final exams coming up on
our first
semester
and all indications are our grades are
going to be good uh but she's got our
finals here in the next few weeks here
but she's had a
longtime boyfriend that's back in our
hometown he is two hours away from her
and we are concerned about him
particularly the influence that he is
having over her
this is a kid the boyfriend that has not
graduated college
or high school he stopped uh
going to school
and uh doesn't live at home with his
parents anymore he's sort of out on his
own
and um there's been talk of
our daughter coming back home
and
not going to college two hours away
because of the normal hey i'm in love
with the with the boyfriend and over the
years the last couple of years
there's been some negative influences
by him
alcohol a little bit him not her
him having his license revoked for a
little bit
those kinds of things
and uh i have a lot of older
buddies i'll say
that
10 years older than me and
trusted friends that i've bounced this
off of and i'm getting a lot of
different opinions on how to handle this
and i think in the past you have
mentioned hey there's a couple levers
you can pull here persuasion
or the economics or financial aspect of
it
by the way my wife and i are paying for
everything
for the daughter car vehicle
food
tuition everything and we plan to do
that for four years
but the the boyfriend is just a bad
influence and um if we clamp down on our
daughter
we are
almost certain uh that she's gonna pick
the boyfriend over
over us and supporting us through
college and um
just not sure how to handle it
what gives you that
that belief you guys there's something
in her
life and her personality that makes you
feel that or is it just straight up fear
any evidence that she would do that
she is strong-willed
where her mental state is now is that
she wants to graduate as fast as
possible
so she can earn a lot of money because
she knows that he is not going to earn a
lot of money because he does not have a
high school diploma
and so she's obviously in love
and
she's doing everything right except for
the boyfriend
where
uh there's a problem now
here is one thought that is going
through
our minds um in
a in a and this is a little crazy idea
but maybe not
um is supporting the boyfriend in other
words being able to prove himself okay
hey come on over to the house for dinner
and let's have a conversation and we
would like to support you in getting
your ged
um
and seeing if he takes us up on the
offer
and if he doesn't
perhaps that proves something to our
daughter and she could see
hey he's not going to
really do what he's supposed to
or
a positive benefit to it is hey we've
supported him even though his family
hasn't supported him as much through the
years
and we're helping him our daughter sees
that hey he gets a ged
and perhaps he's got the ability to get
a decent job
she your youngest
middle one
okay
what's her sister say about all this
uh the sisters the saint the oldest
sister is a senior in college
um
she's about to
graduate whether she doesn't
she doesn't like the boyfriend okay
that's what i was asking yeah it's
simple yeah yeah yeah and then the
younger turn her loose on her sister
yeah
yeah um
i can tell you my three my three have um
policed each other over at that age
group when they were in that age group
uh they don't now because they have
separate households now and they're all
standalone
adults and they you know they re they uh
respect each other's boundaries now but
if one of my both my daughters were in
college at the same time if this had
been going on uh
one of the other ones would have said uh
hey you got to be kidding me this guy's
a loser
and she would have called it out that
way you've been real nice but that's
what you're saying
so i think the other only other thing i
can tell you is you probably
you
more than your wife probably have more
influence with her than you think you do
um and i get that from dr meg meeker and
i would pick up the book matter of fact
i'll send you a copy of it called hero
and it's all about how dads are a hero
and that good dads are a hero in their
daughter's eyes and um you probably can
you're very even-tempered you're not
saying anything flamboyant you're not
going over the top one way or the other
here
you're not abandoning this you're
willing to stand in the gap for her
you're willing to make it difficult for
her for her own good
but you're trying to just be wise about
how to get at this whole thing that
tells me you're probably going to find
the right equation
because of who you are and i think she
knows who you are and i think the guy
i'm talking to is a guy she'll listen to
and it might be you just uh you make a
couple trips over there for saturday
morning breakfast you make the two hour
drive
and just start uh speaking into this
situation very bluntly yeah and say you
know
um i've known guys like this my whole
life and um we love you and we're gonna
walk with you we're not gonna abandon
you
but this is a bad situation and i'm
worried about you because i love you
i i think she'll hear you more than you
think she will yeah that real quick john
i want you to try smothering this kid
with kindness
asking him what is he planning to do put
some kind pressure on him see if it
freaks him out gets him to leave he'll
run him off